as customers move workloads to google
cloud
they need a backup and disaster recovery
offering that provides low
rpo and rto works for a broad set of
applications
and provides ease of use customers may
also want the same cloud-based
backup and disaster recovery offering to
protect some hybrid workloads which will
remain on
premises today customers often use
multiple products for backup disaster
recovery
ransomware resiliency and data
replication for their cloud-based and
hybrid workloads
these architectures have high complexity
and potentially high backup
and recovery times actifio go solves
these challenges using a single pane of
glass that works across google cloud and
hybrid workloads
actifio go is google cloud's backup and
disaster recovery offering that provides
backup and recovery of virtual machines
in google cloud
on compute engine and vmware engine as
well as hybrid vmware environments
backup and recovery of databases and
file systems on google cloud
in hybrid environments and on physical
servers
including sap hana oracle sql
server and other major databases
the ability to leverage google cloud as
a disaster recovery target for
on-premises
and google cloud workloads
using intelligent data capture and
recovery methods
actifio go provides low rpo and low rto
for backup and disaster recovery use
cases
customers can also utilize
cost-effective cloud storage
for long-term retention as well as
disaster recovery
while still achieving rto of minutes by
restoring on-demand in compute
engine or vmware engine as google
cloud's backup and disaster recovery
offering
actifio go enables customers too 1.
protect google cloud and hybrid
workloads from a single pane of glass
while providing application consistent
incremental forever backups
2. reduce the risk of application
downtime with on-demand instant recovery
for mission-critical databases
vms and physical servers including cloud
disaster recovery
3. reduce their data center footprint
and storage costs by backing up vmware
vms directly to google cloud storage
four get started quickly with a simple
consumption-based pricing model that's
integrated with google cloud billing
so if all these great features and
benefits sound interesting to you
head over to the actifio go page in the
google cloud marketplace
thanks for watching
you